[Risas]
[Aplausos]
seguro que todos conocéis esto una
cámara desechable un objeto que tras su
primer uso pierde todo su valor pues
para mí es una herramienta capaz de
transformar nuestras vidas una
herramienta capaz de ayudarnos a
conocernos mejor a nosotros mismos y de
empoderarnos
estará este objeto ha marcado un antes y
un después en mí
mi padre es artista visual y utiliza la
fotografía y recuerdo cuando era pequeño
que me asomaba la puerta de su estudio y
me quedaba maravillado viendo todos esos
flashes y luces de colores me resultaba
algo mágico desde pequeño crecí rodeado
de cámaras me encantaba salir a
fotografiarlo todo inmortalizar momentos
y cuando tuve edad de decidir qué es lo
que quería estudiar tenía claro que
tendría que ver con la creación estudié
comunicación audiovisual y más tarde
hice un máster de fotografía artística
fue ahí donde aprendí que una cámara no
es una simple herramienta de captar
fotografías sino que además es una
herramienta de autoconocimiento de
introspección empecé a conocerme mejor a
mí mismo a leerme a través de mis
propias imágenes aprendí que la
fotografía no es una cuestión de azar
que las decisiones que estamos tomando
al fotografiar parten de lugares de
nuestro interior
y empecé a reflexionar sobre mi infancia
mis privilegios porque yo había podido
tener acceso a la herramienta que tanto
impacto había generado en mí y otros
niños y niñas del mundo no decidí que no
quería aceptar las cosas tal y como son
que quería acercar la magia de la
fotografía a otros niños y niñas del
mundo a los cuales en situaciones no les
permiten acceder a ella porque yo creo
que si no intentamos alcanzar lo
imposible nunca se ampliarán los límites
de lo posible
por todo esto decidí llenar una mochila
de cámaras desechables y trasladarme a
blanc garín y un pequeño poblado de
tanzania allí me encontré con un grupo
de niños que eran felices eran felices
de vivir en una situación que para
nosotros sería muy dura pero que no
conocían otras realidades con las que
compararse no tenían ordenador ni
televisión ni teléfono móvil
estuve enseñándoles fotografía y a las 3
semanas de estar allí les di las cámaras
desechables estas cámaras que yo había
traído para que hicieran sus propias
fotos estuvieron fotografía de su
entorno su día a día y cuando recuperé
las cámaras para llevarlas a revelar yo
estaba pensando que no tenía ninguna
expectativa con el resultado final a mí
lo que me importaba el proceso el
proceso por el cual estos niños y niñas
se expresaban se conocieran mejor a sí
mismos tales como me había pasado a mí
cuando vi las imágenes por primera vez
me quedé sin palabras nunca antes en mi
vida había visto imágenes tan llenas de
verdad imágenes que partían de una
mirada descontaminada sin vicios una
mirada que no entendía de formalismos ni
estéticos ni normativos
una mirada que para mí representaba la
pureza la inocencia de un niño por
ejemplo esta foto de una de las niñas de
en asma es una foto de su habitación
ella en algún lugar habría encontrado
este póster de princesas y mujeres
famosas de las cuales ella no conocía y
le había parecido interesante y lo había
puesto en su pared de barro o esta otra
foto de joshua que al no tener cuaderno
ni papel donde escribir hacía todos los
ejercicios y las cuentas que le mandaban
en la escuela en la puerta de madera de
su casa con tiza
viendo las imágenes me di cuenta de que
podía reconocer a los niños en sus
cámaras era capaz de saber quién había
detrás de cada cámara sin necesidad de
que me lo dijeran y esto pasa porque la
fotografía no es una cuestión de azar a
través de la fotografía nos estamos
expresando y estamos imprimiendo nuestra
personalidad una de las primeras cámaras
que descubrí fue la de hasina una niña
de 9 años que estaba enamorada de los
animales y de las 27 fotografías de su
cámara 25 fueron destinados a ellos
decidí también hacer copias en papel de
las fotos y realizar una pequeña
exposición en el poblado para que los
niños y niñas vieran sus fotos y esto
fue lo que pasó
ya no era solo la primera vez que estos
niños y niñas hacían fotos sino la
primera vez que veían sus fotos impresas
empezaron a reconocerse en cada foto en
cada lugar en cada persona a través de
este proyecto estos niños habían estado
relacionándose con su entorno y
empoderándose de él y de alguna manera
habían empezado a construir los
cimientos de su propia identidad
fue aquí cuando me di cuenta del
verdadero impacto positivo y fundamental
que tiene la fotografía en las personas
fue entonces cuando nació mi proyecto my
view
un tiempo después en madrid sentí que
necesitaba repetir la experiencia estaba
seguro de que tendría que haber niños
niños y niñas a mi alrededor que
pudieran proyectarse con la fotografía
construir su identidad y gracias a una
amiga descubro la situación de la cañada
real el mayor asentamiento irregular de
europa apenas unos kilómetros del centro
de madrid la ciudad donde yo nacido y
crecido decidió trasladarme allí con una
asociación y me encuentro con un grupo
de niños y niñas con los que decido
realizar el proyecto my view
cuando les di las cámaras desechables
estos niños sintieron que formaban parte
de algo que su voz podía ser escuchada
empezaron a sentir el proyecto como
propio y a diferencia de los niños de
tanzania estos niños sí que conocían
otras realidades apenas unos kilómetros
de su casa había otros niños que vivían
con todas las comodidades cubiertas con
una zona de confort de tranquilidad de
seguridad en cambio estos niños no
realizaron sus fotografías por un lado
fotografiaron sus interiores los
interiores de sus casas fotografiaron la
comida a sus madres los espacios donde
duermen sus objetos favoritos
en definitiva fotografiaron lo que para
ellos son las pequeñas bellezas de su
día a día como este jarrón de flores de
plástico
por otro lado fotografiaron los
exteriores su entorno más cercano fueron
fotografiando las cosas que para ellos
eran anecdóticas empieza a encontrar
imágenes de fuego escombros imágenes de
basura
empieza a ver unas imágenes de unos
contenedores de plástico que más tarde
descubro que es donde les rellenan el
agua agua que utilizan para limpiar para
cocinar y hasta para ducharse coches
abandonados y de repente me encuentro
con imágenes desgarradoras que a mi me
llegan dentro por ejemplo esta imagen de
una niña que está cuidando de un gato
protegiéndolo pero está en un ambiente
en un entorno completamente hostil lleno
de escombros de basura
viendo las imágenes empieza a sentir
frustración e impotencia cómo era
posible que unos niños y niñas vivieran
en una cotidianidad así en un entorno
tan hostil apenas a unos kilómetros de
mi casa
diferentes medios de distintos países se
empezaron a hacer eco de las imágenes y
esto era por dos cosas en primer lugar
por la potencia que tenían estas
imágenes y el segundo por el lugar donde
ocurría esto esto estaba pasando en una
capital europea y era un lugar que
siempre que había sido fotografiado
había sido desde el estigma desde la
superficialidad exageración en cambio
estos niños y niñas habían realizado
fotos de su entorno de una manera
natural espontánea sin filtros y es ahí
donde viene su real potencia en la
pureza en la verdad de esas las imágenes
un tiempo después decidió trasladarme
nueve meses a un campo de refugiados en
grecia me acaba la quería conocer en
primera persona cómo se sienten las
familias que han tenido que huir de su
casa de su hogar por culpa de una guerra
que la violencia y la muerte les ha
arrebatado su zona de confort su espacio
de vitalidad allí me encuentro con un
grupo de niños y niñas de siria irak
afganistán que los últimos dos años
habían vivido hasta en cinco países
diferentes que habían olvidado cuál era
su hogar
de nuevo decidió realizar el proyecto my
view con estos niños y empiezan a
fotografiar empiezan a fotografiar su
entorno su día a día pero qué pasa hay
una gran diferencia entre estos niños y
los niños de los anteriores proyectos
estos niños fotografiaban un entorno
temporal transitorio impuesto por la
situación de vida de su país de origen
un lugar que no les pertenecía empiezan
a fotografiar el parque donde van a
jugar el colegio griego al que van todas
las mañanas pero que nadie les entiende
porque no hablan el mismo idioma
de alguna manera en las imágenes yo
podía sentir como estos niños y niñas
estaban segregados aislados
y empiezan a fotografiar los lugares
donde juegan lugares muchas veces si no
has pitos y vacíos
fotografían habitaciones de hotel
convertidas en casas sin apenas objetos
ya que estas familias habían huido de
sus hogares con una mochila y estaban
reconstruyendo su hogar desde cero sin
objetos y memorias
a través de este proyecto estos niños y
niñas sin ser conscientes de ello
estaban relacionándose con su entorno y
de alguna manera reconociendo lo como un
hogar porque al fin y al cabo lo era
este era su hogar y todas las personas
necesitamos sentir que tenemos un hogar
que tenemos el lugar donde sentir donde
estar donde ser
esta foto de una de las niñas sabri de
siria después de hacer la escribió this
is my room esta es mi habitación es una
habitación de hotel donde llevaba dos
años viviendo con su familia y que ella
reconoce como hogar como espacio de
seguridad de confort
de vuelta a madrid empieza a reflexionar
sobre todas las historias que había
escuchado los lugares que había visto
las personas que había conocido y
empieza a ver el proyecto con más
perspectiva empieza a darme cuenta de
que en las fotos hay muchas similitudes
hay patrones que se repiten al fin y al
cabo los niños habían fotografiado las
mismas cosas por un lado sus padres que
son sus referentes habían fotografiado
sus hogares los animales que es donde
proyectan esa admiración por la vida y
de repente me encuentro con esto
qué ves aquí
4 fotos de cuatro gallinas hechas en
cuatro momentos distintos de la historia
en cuatro países diferentes y por cuatro
niños uno de esos niños soy yo de
pequeño aquí me doy cuenta de que todos
los niños y niñas del mundo son iguales
que cuando se acuestan se levantan
siendo eso niños y que ni el lugar donde
hayan nacido ni su color de piel les
distancian
me doy cuenta también de que una cámara
para mí ya no era solo esa herramienta
de captar fotografías y de introspección
sino que además era capaz de generar un
impacto positivo en las personas
ayudando las a relacionarse con su
entorno y empoderarse de él descubro
también señor saber lo que mi proyecto
maybin formaba parte de algo global de
algo que llevaba haciéndose muchos años
en muchos países del mundo que es una
metodología participativa llamada photo
voice y que utiliza la fotografía como
un proceso de conocimiento construcción
y transformación y a través de empoderar
a las personas con cámaras con
fotografías nos permite cambiar nuestra
percepción del mundo
con este proyecto unos cuantos niños y
niñas del mundo que son los verdaderos
protagonistas de esta historia habían
llegado a lugares a los que la razón no
es capaz de llegar ordenando sus
emociones y relacionando las con su
entorno
a través de la fotografía el
subconsciente se activa y las personas
nos proyectamos a través de nuestra
mirada construyendo los cimientos de
nuestra propia identidad
con este proyecto estos niños y niñas
habían estado tomando decisiones
decisiones de que fotografiar el
encuadre la estética decisiones que solo
les correspondían a ellos sin estar
dirigidos sin ningún tipo de norma ni de
condición simplemente siguiendo su
propia intuición planteándose lo como un
juego y es ahí donde de una forma
natural afloraba lo que son
hoy en día estamos acostumbrados a
fotografiarlo todo pero realmente somos
conscientes de la proyección de nosotros
mismos que tienen nuestras fotografías
una cámara desechable tan solo permite
hacer 27 fotos cuáles serían las tuyas
gracias
[Aplausos]